health care providers might be over
counting the number of children that are
hospitalized with covet 19.
new data finds california over counted
child hospital
hospitalizations by at least 40 percent
potentially distorting the national
figures on the effect of the disease on
our children so let's bring in fox news
medical contributor
dr nicole sapphire good morning dr
sapphire good morning ainsley good
morning so
this is based on two different studies
how did this happen why are these
numbers inflated
well ainsley undoubtedly children have
been harmed as a means of some of the
restrictions put in place
to try and keep them safe from covet 19.
while we have acknowledged
for months now that the risk to children
is extremely rare in terms of
hospitalization and death about 77
times less than that for those adults
aged 65 and older
this new study out of stanford may tell
us that even our perceived
low risk of severity in children is
likely even lower than that
this data came out they retrospectively
looked at about 265 patient charts
of children who were hospitalized and
listed as a covet hospitalization
well the data showed about 46 percent of
those children
were likely admitted to that hospital
with had nothing to do with the fact
that they were positive for sars cov2
now that hospitals are universally
testing for the virus when people come
into the hospital
they're finding those infections to be
incidental and about 40 to 45 percent of
those children
were asymptomatic so they just tested
positive for the virus and this
just adds to the body of evidence that
tells us that when children are positive
for the virus they have a very
mild disease course if any symptoms
whatsoever
and you have to remember ainsley we
dealt with this a little bit last summer
where they were talking about
inflating hospitalization and death
counts for people
even adults and you know we have to be
careful because there is a perceived
risk
and that is what a lot of these
restrictions are based upon
but it is prudent that we get this risk
right as we know that we have harmed our
children
and adults when it comes to a lot of
these restrictions so
this just again adds to that growing
data that
the risk to children is very low and
while more and more adults young adults
and adolescents continue to get
vaccinated and
our percent positivity of tests have now
hit an all-time low
of about 2.7 percent it's time to allow
our children to get back to that level
of normal life
knowing that they are not a risk to
society and the risk of coba 19 to them
is negligible that's the problem with
these these studies they inflate the
numbers and then
our experts make decisions for our
children based on those numbers and then
we find out months later a year later
all of that
was not necessarily true most of those
kids that were still testing positive
but did not have any symptoms were in
the hospital for surgeries cancer
treatment urologic issues
psychiatric issues thank you so much dr
sapphire for being on with us
absolutely